Jay Silverman: it's either on the page or it's not on
the page. Scott Kirkpatrick: This whole industry doesn't
exist with people twiddling their thumbs
waiting for the right script to drop
into their hands. Stanley Brooks: Well I'm not sitting
here for an hour waiting for you to tell
me that. Rachel. K. Ofori: I need to know how I feel after
I read it if I feel like what was I
supposed to feel now there's you gotta
go back to your drawing board. Mark Heidelberger: You say
your main relationship is Character A and
Character B but your antagonist is character
C.  Wendy Kram: That says so much more than anything
that's on the nose and obvious.John Paul Rice: Script is
your heart and soul, the spine of the
whole thing that you're going to build
off of the foundation of everything that
you're going to lay on top of it.
I try and read a script that's
to me as an audience first so the first
thing I'm looking at is it does it grab
me do I care
is it a story that I feel emotional
about compelled by you know if it's a
scary movie am I scared
it's the comedy have I laughed if it's
emotional have I you know gotten a lump
in my throat I find that if I'm looking
at it and dissecting it right from the
start and I'm not doing myself any
favors and I'm not doing the script any
favors
if I get to I don't know at some point
it hasn't done any of those things I
usually don't finish it but if I get to
the end and I have felt those things
then I'll go back and do a second read
as with my producer had on for one like
I said emotional response like I need to
know how I feel after I read it if I
feel like what was I supposed to feel
now there's you got to go back to your
drawing board so yes yeah the know the
feeling the feeling needs to be there
some something some type of feeling at
the end of it
the other thing is a true identity and
what genre it is and if it's not it's
okay cuz I can I can do that I can help
with that
but if the person doesn't know what
genre they're in it's not that you have
to play by the rules but you need to
know the rules before you break them and
they're telling me oh I just made this
awesome horror film and I'm like this is
hilarious like we just watch it and
horror and comedy can intertwine but
it's like you're gonna break a rule here
let me make sure this is what you meant
by this like so I need to have a really
strong identity in its genre and I don't
care what the story is in terms of genre
or you know people ask me like you know
do you care about a certain genre and
they're yeah you seem to work in all
different genres I said yeah because I
mean to me a good story transcends genre
it has nothing to do with genre genres
just sort of a set of conventions that
allow people to identify what kind of
movie it is and therefore whether they
want to see it or not but genre has
nothing to do with whether you could
tell good story in any genre and to me
working in different genres part of the
excitement of working in this business
like that's why so many of us love being
in this business right we don't go to
the same office necessary every day and
we can we're always pursuing something
different
sort of character some sort of
protagonist can identify with his
journey in some way I'm I'm gonna use
the word likeable I'm just gonna say is
it like a protagonist I can identify
with in some way I want to follow him
for some reason you know it does he have
goals does he have flaws is there an
antagonist that's creating conflict with
this guy and you know a girl whatever
the situation is but is there there
something I can get behind
another thing it needs to have is
somebody that either I can't say rooting
for but someone that a mass audience
like most people can connect with we're
in a time where you know people are a
little bit more open to different things
so I think that's that's something that
we're kind of having to like test the
the thermometer on like where are we as
a culture like what is now accepted or
whatever but you have a good idea just
from living life and watching the news
like what people accept or scroll
through the social media you could get
an idea of how they connect with things
and how they they see things so if I
have no one in that film that I see
myself in there's a problem cuz I can
see myself a lot of ways I'm very
versatile I don't think I'm like this
person that has to only see this and
only see that so if I don't see
something that I can connect with we're
missing something so a connection to a
character does not the main character
but a connection to a character in a way
that brings a person in we're like okay
that could be my buddy yeah I would say
that too or whatever if it's so far off
in like overly avant-garde or artsy I
just need to be told then this is what
that's supposed to be and then alright
great you want to make it here's a
little teeny budget and I'll help you
get into some weird festivals like you
know if they're like no I want this to
be on every you know like well we can't
work together because that's not gonna
work so yeah as long as as long as it
has someone that can connect to
I think screenwriters stand their best
chance of really getting noticed by
knowing what the business needs so it's
not coming in talking about how
passionate you are about the scripts
it's talking and speaking in a way that
answers to the needs of the production
company the producer of the studio etc
it's there are tried and tested genres
that are just they they just nail what
the business lives on and if you're if a
young writer wants to come into the
business and really just get their
emails answered get the phone calls
returned it's being able to speak about
their project and have it answer to
those things it's it's gonna be saying
I'm writing a family film about this I'm
writing a film about this and it's a
very quick point it's not it's you know
never coming-of-age stories it's never
dramas it's it's happier films it's it's
the kinds of films you see on a Redbox
machine that's what Hollywood needs to
stay in business and so if you're coming
to the table bringing opportunities for
Hollywood to continue staying in
business they're gonna pay attention to
you never at any point am I saying
don't write dramas don't write comedies
don't write the coming-of-age story if
you have a fantastic idea for a movie I
think a writer should hold on to just
hold on to it wait like get the
commercial scripts out first get a
reputation of being our screenwriter who
can deliver what the system needs who
can write quickly who can write well who
can write within budget and get a couple
of actual paid gigs and you'll get them
if you go in the opposite way saying I
know what Hollywood wants they want this
they want these very deep dramas
coming-of-age dramas and forcing them to
do that it's not you're not going to get
noticed but if you come in giving them
what they want which are like tween girl
family films or Christmas movies with
dogs women in peril thrillers these
kinds of things
Hollywood pays attention to you and once
you are writing those and once you're
getting noticed for that work
then you have a collection of contacts
and you can say I have an interesting
idea could this work and then you can
present those
what's the genre is its studio or
independent who's your protagonist
what's their goal with their flaw who's
the main relationship with what's
driving this story who's your audience
who's the antagonist what's their goal
and their flaw
you know what's the narrative question
driving the film so like every story you
should be able to sum it up in one main
question like so like die if I was die
hard would be like you know will you
know a New York cop trapped you know
will this New York cop free his wife and
hostages from some European terrorists
you have them trapped in skyscrapers
like it's like one question right like
so like what's your narrative question
driving this story and what's your theme
and what's your theme attic question
like what's why are you telling us that
the Ematic question is like the question
you posed to the audience it could be a
moral question it could be or something
else but some question you want them to
think about like it is family really
just people you're related to or is it
something more you know it could be your
fee Matic question it's it's not overtly
stated in the story but it's kind of
like in the film subconscious it's like
what you know the film is really kind of
about and then your theme is how you
answer that question by the end that's
your theme ager your story so like what
are those things and I might even be
missing a couple ayat but off the top of
my head those are like a lot of and if
you can't answer those questions
or if those questions don't make sense
together a lot of times there's the
problems with the story so for example
if you say your protagonist goal is my
protagonist goal is to grab the banana
and what's your antagonist goal to grab
the orange well they're in two different
movies they're never going to intersect
there's no conflict great your
protagonist grabs the banana and your
antagonist grabs you wants movies over
and that's a very simplistic example but
those are the kind of things but on a
deeper level we look at my goal wall
here there's a few things that aren't
making sense you say your main
relationship is character and character
BB or antagonist character C they're not
even and meet in your main relationship
that's moving the story forward so why
are they that why are they your
antagonist so 12 questions from and this
is from amateur writers who have never
had anything sold what I you know call
development cases people that you're you
have a belief in because they're
talented you're trying to get them there
all the way up to you know experienced
screenwriters who have had
you know a half dozen pictures produce
you know the the 12 questions is a great
sort of reset okay let me square away I
mean you know even if I've done this a
hundred times every story is different
in a lot of times you miss those those
important details and once I think that
twelve questions are are making sense
now and things are tying together like
oh now see how the protagonist goal ties
into your theme okay now everything
starts puzzle pieces start making sense
then I say okay now now let's work out a
synopsis three or four paragraphs you
know first exit can I throw that or
whatever just so we can say okay now
let's make sure from just a broad story
standpoint that all those questions are
being addressed and then from there you
can expand it to a full treatment scene
outline and it's then you start writing
your script cuz like I explained to them
a lot easier to develop the story in a
synopsis form or a treatment form than
it is to keep rewriting the script when
there's fundamental problems in it you
don't start building the building it's
slanted all right let's start taking out
some bricks and try to get you you work
all of that out on the design phase and
the blueprint phase and so that's what I
try to get them to do it and the twelve
questions is to me is like okay that's
that beginning that organic seed that we
need to plant to make a healthy tree
grow
I said you you have any scripts I'm
looking for something that features
somebody with a disability that's simple
to do small cast simple locations and
that's when I read carol of the bells
and it met that criteria I'm looking to
do you know because like in Bakersfield
the community works with us
so locations you can get for free they
just open their doors to you there so
you're getting really good production
value we made a great deal with the
hotels and the the the way we did it was
each facility like Bakersfield has mine
I own and the other ones are like
franchises so they sent two pros down
and two students and then we used all
our students that were ready to work to
make this and so the criteria for that
was limited locations getting as much
production value as you can with no
money and again its borrowing stealing
whatever but it's going in and you know
going into someone's house and saying
hey you know we'd love to shoot here we
don't have any money would you let us
use your house and finding some
beautiful locations and people working
with you so it's a good way to learn
filmmaking you know to do without when
you produce something because then later
when you have money it's like oh a
filmmaker typically doesn't have just
one project that he's interested in
doing in my case I have a pretty
important mandate I'm only looking to do
projects that are personally beneficial
to the world and I'm not talking about
pollution or something like that I'm
talking about a meaningful project that
that would help people engage and and
and see things filmmaking is so
brilliant that's the kind of films that
I want to make films that viscerally
help you understand the world more and
maybe make you more tolerant may
make you more perceptive and you know
certainly filmmaking is one of the best
vehicles other than speech and to me our
book filmmaker you know really has an
opportunity to tell story and with the
the belief not in purposeful preaching
but the belief is you'll walk out and
you'll have a perspective you might
never have had if I feel like the
projects lacking but I can but I feel
like I can find my passion as we work on
it sometimes I look at and I say you
know but this guy really liked working
with them I see how we can make this
project better and I know this person
who's hiring me is open to the creative
development process they're open to
hearing out my ideas and letting me
whether it's an executive producer
whether it's a lot of times get hired by
the writer director and they have
financing from somewhere but they don't
want to do that day to day producing and
so I'll come on is the main producer or
I'll come on as a producer with them as
long as I believe that they're open to
the creative process and that I can read
that script and go
I can I can get passionate about this I
can find my passion as we work on it I
don't need to be passionate from the
second I read it once I sign on the
dotted line you hire me and I'm involved
in producing this picture I'm a hundred
and ten percent into the picture it's
not you know I'm not so sure you're not
you're not passionate about it at first
once I put my name on the dotted line
that picture has my undivided attention
I'm gonna make it as great as I can be
as long as I see the potential for it to
be great and a potential for me to be
able to put my finger prints on it and
be able to find my passion as we work on
it yeah I'll you know I'll sign on to
that I'll sign on to that project as
long as I see that potential
so my level discernments a little bit
different than someone's having to put
up their own money and go out and chase
me chase but it allows me to work on a
whole lot of other projects that I might
not have otherwise even known about and
then and also make a living doing it
which is nice when you can make a living
doing what you love
if there's dialogue on the page that
takes up half a page or almost the whole
page that's a telltale sign of with
exception of course there are always
exceptions but that would be a sign that
it's an amateur if there's pages in a
script that are so dense that it looks
like a novel that would be another sign
if there's like page after page of in
very dense descriptions that will wind
up in and the recycle bin or trash and
uh your computer
she's got 56 characters and he knew
right away bingo that that was going to
translate into a portion of the budget
that was disproportionate with what we
had and what does that mean in English
only affordable amount of characters we
could have in his opinion was between 20
and 25 characters and I know that sounds
crazy but any independent filmmakers
gonna come in front of the same moment
that I came in front of when you go do
you really need that character to walk
in the door go hey you got a phone call
that character is a SAG talking actor
and that's gonna cost you X amount of
dollars and you put 40 more of those in
the movie and you've made a movie that
you're not going to be able to afford
and it's crazy and you know I know that
you're interviewing me about creativity
but if you can get this stuff off the
table before you start talking
creativity you'll have you know in my
opinion a more controllable project if
in the script there are there's a plot
aspects or character behavior that's not
clear to me or confusing or inconsistent
I'll just ask the question and I always
tell the writer that they never to feel
compelled to agree with me it's not a
dictatorial thing but it is for the
purpose of I feel I'm a pretty good
barometer of what other how other
executives are are going to respond to
material and if it's not clear to me
then there's a good chance that it might
not be clear to someone else so they
don't have to I never feel like I want
to impose something to be done a certain
way but I will raise a question or I'll
say
I feel that this dialogue it doesn't
feel authentic to me it feels like
there's an agenda the writer has an
agenda that you want the character to
say this but I think if we're really
looking in the scene and a daughter is
responding to her mother how much she
really respond and I'll ask the writer
to go back and kind of try and find the
truth rather than the written agenda if
that makes sense so well you can
immediately tell when a script has not
been written by a professional and
obviously that well that's a big red
flag so if the script has like art on
the title page or colored paper or is
not in final draft form you know too
much too much of a header or too much on
the size you know with okay those person
is either trying to get something to be
shorter or longer by using the margins
which that's not playing fair so so
those would say red flags are things
like you know not introducing your
protagonist and the first ten page is
not you know announcing what your film
is you know in the first 15 pages you
know don't don't wait until halfway
through to tell me oh this movies about
this guy who wants to kill his mom okay
well well I'm not sitting here for an
hour waiting for you to tell me that so
so I'm looking for the kind of
structural and character problems that
are pretty easy to spot you know I'm not
a big believer in the Robert McKee world
of inciting incident and all that but
there's value in what he has to say sort
of philosophically which is that there
are some kind of foundational things you
need to do in a screenplay that you
don't you know unless you're doing
experimental movies which I'm not in
that business if you have a story to
tell there are certain you know parts of
the roadmap you got a hit and so you
know you hold back your protagonist
until page 30 and that's just not going
to happen
there's no you're not acting
has SK a movie star to show up a half
hour into the movie so those are the
kinds of things I look for
and I just say in terms of marketability
what gets agents attention producers
studio networks is that you'll hear a
strong voice that there's something
really fresh about a person has a point
of view and that the character writing
the Quentin Tarantino is such a strong
voice and I would say that Greta Gerwig
you know as a strong voice the
truthfulness of that mother-daughter
relationship which wasn't pretty
you know how they got in each other
spaces and talked to each other but it's
was truthful and we know that they they
did love each other and you know so
touching towards latter part of the
movie when the mother who was really
kind of you know really tough with her
daughter and the daughter didn't feel
like she really loved her even liked her
and then we saw that she was trying to
write a letter to her and crumbled it up
like 30 times that's a that's another
form of love versus this would be the
boring way of doing it and not so
truthful to the human experience would
be well you know I love you maybe I'm
hard on you but maybe I'm doing it for
your own good or maybe have my own
issues so I'm not really able to love
that well versus the simple beautiful
act that she was crumpling up letters
because she want to find the right words
and couldn't that says so much more than
anything that's on the nose and obvious
if I could say that there was a mistake
that writers make is it's not giving
themselves the time or space to listen
to how they add to a story or a
situation that they write what they
think that the market wants that they
think that will sell without actually
finding something that is that makes
them excited about the telling and that
has a personal resonance with them so
especially younger writers they have to
learn it's cliche but they have to learn
how to find their voice and they have to
value the fact that no matter what their
age or experience level they've got
something of value to bring out
and so the key thing is not to develop
what other people have done but to work
on developing your voice and I've never
met a writer who isn't a reader the most
significant writers I've ever worked
with are very well-read individuals and
I love that because you have to get you
have to feed the well somehow you have
to get ideas and you understand so much
more about that internal space you want
to live through when you're diving into
it regularly with good books
it has to be relevant to the immediate
culture that doesn't mean it needs to be
happening but just relevant for instance
I think some movies that were so good
that didn't do well it was like if they
just waited a couple more years it would
have worked because we were moving to
that but this guy has a very strong
opinion on it this director or this
writer or whatever so if he's gonna come
with this opinion it's gonna kind of
disconnect and people are not gonna
spread it or find answers you're not
gonna get down with it or you know the
distributor won't readily just open the
door they'll probably throw it on
Netflix somewhere and bury it or
whatever it's because they just it was
such a good project such a good story
but it just wasn't time for it yet and I
think for producers they have to be very
mindful of that it's not just keeping up
with current events it's kind of just
talking to people and making sure that
you're in a very diverse group of people
I think every producer if you're only
talking to your buddies from school it's
a problem need to talk to people from
different backgrounds different
financial backgrounds different races
different ethnicity everything you need
to expand your horizons travel when you
go to even if you just travel a state
over go to like don't go to Applebee's I
mean but like Applebee's when you're
home but if you're in another place go
to like the little mom-and-pop and just
kind of sit at a diner and talk to some
people because I'm thinking wow this is
such a great idea I go to Montana these
people will never watch this so it's
okay that's not it's but I gotta keep
that in mind so if I'm not I have no
idea what's going on I think like even
with the political culture right now
people I didn't know people it's not
like this I'm like I did it I toured all
the country doing merchandise events
like I believe me this is nothing new
but it's like that's necessary when
you're the person a producer that is is
in a position to choose what stories are
made or choose which stories you're
going to push through or find financing
for choose the right ones for the time
until the person is not ready they might
fight you on it you might lose a project
and they might do it anyway and then
you'll see that they you were right
but if you communicate in a way a person
can get down with it and then for
writers just know like while you're
writing let yourself run free but also
be aware of what's happening around you
and that doesn't mean your idea can't
happen you just might
just it so it's like the little you know
like sugar with the medicine type of
thing like a little bit of sugar just a
low sugar in it so it's a little bit
more palatable for where we're at
that way we can spread it to the world
and everyone can see your art but if
you're staying in this space and you're
futuristic and you have this whole idea
where we're going like okay let's now we
got an atom or budget make a futuristic
then it can't be now because we're not
there yet or whatever so yeah being very
mindful of what's happening what the
culture is and seeing when I'm reading
that script
can someone accept this as truth right
now and you do there'll always be a
couple knows and you got to know who
those noes are but if it's mostly yeses
all right we can now move forward
portable can we do this will there be a
part in it for a star which as you know
thinks that things that are too ensemble
are difficult to get made because you
need a star role to get things ordered
usually so you know I'm looking I have
the night deployment Hamelin and then
the producer hat goes ok what where
would I shoot this how much is it gonna
cost is there a star role where is there
network or studio that would buy this
because you don't obviously chase
something that there's no place to sell
and so then that's the second read it is
a budget range that's reasonable so a
lot of people they come to me and I get
a lot of how much would it cost to do
this script and I'm like well I'll tell
you what I'll answer that question if
you can answer a question for me how
long is a piece of string that's what I
like to ask them you can't just give me
a script how much does it cost to make
that was Matt Damon in your movie right
well your budget just went up by 10
million dollars I mean I can make an
argument to do this movie for a million
bucks or 10 million bucks
so really it's more like how much can
you raise and then you know or or how
much do you have or you know if they if
they really don't have a good idea of
this who do you see in it how why do you
see it being distributed but I have to
get an idea of sort of what range and
how big they're seeing this in their
head and a lot of times I might read the
not a lot of times but sometimes a
migrator script yeah well that's not
gonna that's not gonna happen on this
you know you're not gonna do avatar on a
$500,000 budget or whatever the first
thing I asked a person before we even
read the script is where do you see this
going and that kind of tells me and it's
funny someone's always like oh I never
thought of that and I'm like well yeah
you have to know where you're going to
know how to do it you have to know where
you're going to know where to move in
where to focus on and we're two-faced so
if they don't know where this if they
wanted to go that's gonna make my job a
little harder now I can read it and be
like oh this can do this but at least
let me know where you see it and then
when I'm reading it I can kind of say
yeah you got it or you don't and are you
fine with not having that you would have
this outcome are you good with that yeah
you know I yeah great
or no I'm not well you're gonna have to
go back to this rewrite it have much
less location so we can get you a bigger
star because this thing is not going to
sell you know like something like that
so yes a good I guess that would be
direction a good focus point of
where they wanted to go that helps me
when I look at a script I'm thinking
about a lot of different thing about all
those things specifically how how they
relate budget wise and fiscally but also
you know how that hmm you know the
creative and the fiscal will work
together so you know when I read the
script I'm thinking about story and I'm
thinking about the arc of the characters
and I'm thinking about if conflict I
don't think about why are we telling
this story but I'm also thinking okay
who would I get to play these could I
get to play these roles on this budget
level like what are some decent names
who am i picturing in this you know I'm
thinking about and if I mean I'm
presuming in this situation that the
movie's real that's not just a script
I'm not just reading it for fun but it's
like okay we're making this picture like
this pictures funded mark read the
script so I'm reading and I'm like okay
how we gonna pull off that we need that
this kind of grandiose house production
design in the house I'm looking at some
of these things and I'm saying you know
okay we need this and we need we need to
dress the kid's room like this okay you
know there's a very specific style do I
know somebody who might be able to
execute that style it's very postmodern
I've worked with it at the production
designer that did this and Wow sound is
such a big deal
you know some thinking about all these
all of these things as I'm reading it as
opposed to and actors reading it yes
they're considering story I think
everybody with some sort of creative you
know position is thinking about story to
some degree but actor is gonna be much
more focused on their role in the arc of
their role and the Scimitar there's
gonna be much more focus they're gonna
be reading and seeing something totally
different they're gonna say oh wow okay
so we got a bunch of exterior night out
here by the pool we're gonna light the
pool how we gonna light I'm gonna light
the water how we gonna they're gonna be
looking at it that way I see you got the
shot that follows them through the house
and so they're gonna want to talk to the
director about how that I'm thinking
about all that stuff but I'm thinking
about like okay do we're gonna have the
budget for those kind of lights and
creatively if we can't pull something
off how are we gonna be able to you know
to make that we can't pull that off with
the budget or or there's some other
logistical circumstance that's gonna
make that unreasonable what are we gonna
have to change in the script to do that
and I'm also a line producer in a upm so
I am I'm breaking down the script I am
thinking about all of these things okay
we need Steadicam to pull that off and
we need that so I really do get down to
that level of detail but
it to some degree but I I'm thinking
about everything you know in one form or
fashion as it rates to creative and
fiscal and how those two things work
together and I think I think probably a
lot of other I think writers are
probably focused more on story and not a
lot of not necessarily on the logistics
so when I talk to them I'm like but how
are we gonna pull this off you know yeah
well so from a producer producers
perspective we're talking we're thinking
more about execution well I think a lot
of writers just they just tell the story
they want to tell and they don't
necessarily think about how it'll be
done which is fine you're the writer
that's your job just get the story out
but when it starts to become real and
then we have to start approaching how
we're gonna do it sometimes some things
for logistical reasons have to have to
shift script dictates the budget script
is your heart and soul the spine of the
whole thing that you're gonna build off
of the foundation of everything that
you're gonna lay on top of it and if you
have money first and you're writing to
the budget of that I think your
creativity is is paramount and then
dealing with in the realities of you
know what's what resources are available
to you right and then you start talking
about money and how you're gonna fulfill
that vision but if the vision is coming
from a monetary at me personally I I've
had more money on some of my other films
didn't mean I did a better job producing
in fact my third film mother's red dress
I had more money than any of the other
ones and it was my worst job producing
why because I because I thought that by
having more money to pay more money to
each position and person that was
working on it I was just gonna get
better talent and therefore I took my my
my better part of myself out of the
equation just that it was gonna be
solved by money and I learned a very
valuable lesson on that we got the film
done and everything was great and it
worked out fine but I I saw dollars and
that I could get this kind of DP and it
didn't translate into success for the
project in fact the person that I
brought on once that DP left the project
for
another project in the middle of
shooting yeah I brought in somebody else
that had less equipment less experience
and he did a fantastic job because his
motivation was correct so so if you if
you look at it from this standpoint if
you have money and you're gonna pay
people right I mean we all want to get
paid and we got to work to live and all
that but but if that is the focus first
then I think that the you're doing the
opposite it's like okay we've got a
marketing campaign we can do now let's
find a script if it's you know the the
kind of content that we want to sell as
opposed to what comes from within
working with this person do I you know
do I get a good good sense because
you're gonna spend a year or more
dealing with this person depending on
the scope of my duties so you know
sometimes I'm just literally brought on
to there's no development I'm like okay
the scripts decent you know and I think
I can influence it enough through the
production process to make it a good a
good picture and then at post when I
deliver the master drive or the DCP or
whatever the final deliverable is I'm
done I'm not involved in marketing or
distribution there are projects like
that and just depends on the term of the
contract so but I would say at the least
I'm spending at least a year with this
person so so yeah well-written script
reasonable budget and logistics and and
I like the person those are really my
main criteria
it's important to remember that movies
and TV shows cost an incredible amount
of money to produce and if there's
nobody to watch it on the backside or to
transact upon it on iTunes or at a movie
theater then there's not much of a point
in doing that and there's there's an
even more expensive aspect of producing
something which is marketing it and
getting it out in front of people so
they know it exists so that when they're
interested in seeing it and ready to buy
tickets or download it behind a paywall
and pay money for it they have the
ability to do it and they're ready to do
it right away so that's the financial
end so people in my position Paul I mean
from where I'm working all the way up to
top executives at studios what those
people the end users want to see is
really really important and that's kind
of where we're thinking because if the
end users are interested in seeing it
then international countries would be
interested in also having access to it
and they would be willing to invest
money to have access to it early which
is where the whole presale game kind of
comes into play or you know a TV channel
here in the US if they know their
audience wants something very specific
they will kind of work to have that
produced on their network and they'll
kind of work backwards
you know first finding out what kind of
project it's got to be the types of
people who have to be in it and then
working their way backwards to get to
the point of actually drafting writing
and creating and all that so on the big
scale for these major major productions
at the studio level or the major network
level that's why they go for things like
major franchises or very well-known
books or very well-known media
properties are doing remakes there's
already an audience there they already
kind of have an estimate of how it's
gonna be you know get from point A to
point B and that's where the business
side of it really plays it's what is it
how is it going to work where
the money coming from and who's going to
get paid what to make this whole process
happen that's got to all be figured out
before you really hone in on the right
script most screenwriting books
approach it as you write a story and it
evolves into a movie and this whole
industry doesn't exist with people
twiddling their thumbs waiting for the
right script to drop into their hands it
works the opposite direction which is we
know we need this type of content to be
successful we have certain channels or
certain just you know platforms that we
have to cater to with content so that's
the stuff we're going to be looking for
as finished content or we'll go make it
ourselves